on my business card I am a corporate
president in my mind I am a game
developer but in my heart I am a gamer
hello and welcome to the point now we
promised you a new show last week and we
had one plan but instead today we're
going to take a moment to reflect on the
life and work of mr. satoru iwata who
sadly passed away at the age of 55 late
last week
his name Satoru means to understand and
this week I spent a lot of time watching
over his many on-camera appearances to
try and get an understanding of the
impact that he had on our industry and
the lessons he leaves behind and in
doing so I kept coming back to this
building in fact one particular day
almost exactly 10 years ago you see this
is the Moscone Center West and it's here
of year that the Game Developers
Conference keynote speeches are held and
it was here in 2005 that a WOD asan
first took to the stage he would return
here numerous times again in 2006 2011
and 2013 but I want to focus on this day
in particular as it speaks to several
aspects of a man who loved games and who
wanted as many people as possible to
love them too
so join me today as we celebrate the
life of Satoru Iwata his influence on
the game industry and the many lessons
he leaves us behind today I'd like to
speak to you from my heart about our
jobs and about our industry the water
was born in Sapporo on the northern
Japanese island of Hokkaido his father
was the mayor of the city the fourth
largest in Japan as the story goes he
learned to make games on a programmable
calculator his first a baseball
simulator made solely of numbers that he
enjoyed watching his friends playing
after high school owada traveled to
Tokyo to study computer science at the
Institute of Technology in a time long
before video game development was
considered a respectable career he
complimented his education with hands-on
work taking up an unpaid internship at
Commodore Japan and once he graduated
him and his friends moved into an
apartment in the city's famous Akihabara
district where they stayed up late
making and playing video games this was
the foundation of how a game studio
named after the AI from 2001 a Space
Odyssey and a studio that worked closely
with Nintendo creating games for the NES
beyond and it's here that owada came
into his own he programmed his first nes
game balloon fight saved the Troublesome
development of earthbound and produced
the Kirby franchise the studio is also
known for creating the super popular
Smash Brothers series the wildly
successful brawler has seen releases on
every Nintendo console since but when
owatta initially pitched it Nintendo
weren't on board I also remember the
first version of smash version developed
for Nintendo 64 the concept for the game
as you know was to take the classic
rendering intent of franchise characters
and have them as you say here in America
beat the heck out of each other the
concept did not sound hip or cool or
revolutionary and because of all this
there were people both inside and
outside Nintendo who did not strongly
favor our idea that attitude remain
until the moment of truth the moment
when pistols began picking up the
controllers and actually playing the
game this is what happened people smiled
then laughed then began shouting to each
other that was the moment when
everything for smash brothers
changed and I must tell you this was
also one of them proudest moment in my
development career this is the essence
of Huaraz mentality making lateral
decisions that most wouldn't and
allowing feedback from gamers to dictate
whether was a success or not
like his calculator game the proof was
in the faces of those who played it but
a water had other plans to to expand the
reach of games to sail the ship of games
in this
Guerry uncharted waters and he was about
to become the captain of the biggest
ship in Japan and what his business
acumen would see him rise through the
ranks to become the head of how in the
mid-90s when the studio was on the verge
of bankruptcy he saved it stabilizing
its accounts and ensuring the games kept
coming house still makes games today
they just released Kirby and the rainbow
curse on Wii U earlier this year but
threat is time in the boardroom he never
stopped programming helping Nintendo
with the development of pokemon gold and
silver for the Game Boy Color reportedly
creating a compression tool which
allowed the game to be twice as large
he also programmed pokemon stadium for
the n64 by rewriting the code from red
and green and then at the crest of the
century right after the release of Super
Smash Bros it water jumped ship to
Nintendo to head its corporate planning
division here he would help the company
recover from the disappointing selling
game queue but it was a position he
wouldn't hold for long as in 2002 he was
appointed the head of Nintendo the first
with no family ties to the EMU cheese
the founding family who operated
Nintendo through three generations and
while Hiroshi Yamauchi would still act
as his mentor from behind the scenes and
what as risk-taking gamer centric
approach to development became the
backbone of a new Nintendo this is where
we catch up with his speech ten years
ago on this stage and a water buoyed by
the critical and commercial response to
the DS a console that many said would be
killed by the PSP as the GameCube was by
the ps2 speaks about what he believes is
the future of video games do you have
friends and family members who do not
play video games well why don't they and
I would ask this how often have you
challenged yourself to create a game
that you might not play I think this
question form an important challenge for
all of us we work every day to make what
we describe as video games better we
want to give players what they want
but at the same time we are intent on
finding out what else we can use to
entertain our second goal is to show
failure something new something they may
not even know they want the Nintendo
DS's go on to be the highest selling
hand out of all time and second highest
selling console period shipping 154
million units worldwide meeting at the
Gameboy by over 30 million he would do
this by using the mind of a developer
creating a system that programmers spend
easy to create on like gunpei Yokoi did
with the gameboy by using existing
technology instead of trying to chase
the next big thing and by appealing to
the part of gamers by ensuring beloved
Nintendo franchises came to the console
on mass but his greatest achievement was
in sailing into those unknown seas by
supplementing Nintendo classics with
games like brain age and Nintendogs
which appealed to entirely new breeds of
gamer massive parts of society that had
long been ignored by the video gaming
world specifically young girls women and
adults and by using new ways of
interacting with the machine losing
complicated button configurations in
favor of touch screens which a decade
later we now use every day I was in this
very building at GDC 2005 that he spoke
of an even bigger revolution there was
only a couple of months later in his
adopted home of Tokyo that we first
caught glimpse of him we're used to CEOs
waxing lyrical about their plans but
there's no denying that the Wii was a
revolution and the single most
disruptive console in the history of
gaming an entirely new way of
interacting with a console new ways of
playing games new genres and critically
like the DS with an approachable control
method most people know how to use a
remote control the Wii controller
brought the barrier of entry for console
gaming lower than it had ever been this
is the essence of a wadis philosophy new
experiences better experiences and
experiences that everyone could enjoy
and even if you weren't a fan of the Wii
or a fan of Nintendo you can't deny that
evolution and revolution is essential to
gaming that's why we can forgive the Wii
U because risk is essential regardless
of the outcome it water believe that and
as somebody who loved games who made
games whose life Direction was the
find by games he pushed games forward
this is a CEO who talked directly to his
customers who define success up by
spreadsheets but by the smiles on gamers
faces and a man who took his
responsibilities as one of gaming's
leaders with such severity and pride
that he continued to work at Nintendo
right up until this tragically early
death
I ran the same time we post this video
on July 17 mr. Awad his body will be
being laid to rest
Mariana Evans said I dad I never dead
until we have forgotten them so in many
ways Satoru Iwata will always be with us
as long as we remember the lessons that
he left us the gamers understand that
risk is to be celebrated and that
developers understand that success isn't
measured on spreadsheets on the faces of
those who play their games
Thank You Satoru Iwata may he rest in
peace even if we come from different
sides of the world speak different
languages even if we eat too many chips
or rice balls even if we have different
tastes in games everyone know us here
today is identical in the most important
way each one of us has the heart of the
game
thank you very much for you
[Music]
you